hi I'm Nick Gillespie I'm with Matt
Welch we work at reason and were the
co-authors of the new book the
Declaration of Independence and on ask a
libertarian day the next question is
from Kyle Johnson who asked why has the
libertarian movement succumb to
infighting and self-destruction so many
times in the past Matt Welch three
reasons one some of it reflects a
genuine conflict within self-described
libertarian camp between people who are
seeking a kind of pure philosophical
expression of every question and those
who are trying to figure out you know
how much can we get away with basically
it's pragmatism versus versus the
philosophical bent and that is a natural
conflict that's been there second reason
people who are attracted to marginal
movements or philosophies tend to be
marginal I'm marginal Nick God knows is
marginal and those aren't necessarily
the best people to play well and nicely
with others but third I challenge the
premise of your question Kyle Johnson
I'm not sure that the libertarian
movement has succumbed to anything
whatever it is now I think is
demonstrably greater than it has been in
a long time and partly because a lot of
the people who are libertarian in fact
if not in label they see it less as a
you know exact set of positions that
you're supposed to hold and take it more
of a kind of pre political impulse as
Nick has always said more of an
adjective than a noun and for that
reason that because politics right now
as currently practice is so anti
libertarian on every front there is a
groundswell of actual libertarians in
this country that's much bigger than it
husband yeah I would say that in the
past the infighting and self-destruction
was so huge
because the stakes were so low and that
now the stakes are higher libertarianism
is the surging plurality of Americans
through a lot of different ways people
like free minds and free markets as we
call it at reason
and I think you're going to see not
people going along to get along but the
libertarian impulse will not be denied